- We're rolling over here!
- Guys, we're rolling!
(crew laughing)
(upbeat rock music)
- I love Truth or Dare.
I love Would You Rather?
I love Two Truths and a Lie.
(upbeat rock music)
Arrow.
- Okay, that's easy for her answer.
- I thought we were supposed
to do it as fast as possible.
Would you rather? Huh!
- Oh.
Is that the way the
game's played, super fast?
- Oh, that's how we used to play it.
- Okay, all right, okay.
- I'm adding rules.
Lightning speed, let's do it.
- Yeah.
- [Both] Arrow.
- Flash, 'cause we can talk tech.
- Flash.
- Arrow, he's got muscles.
- I think Flash.
Sweep me off my feet.
- No comment.
(laughing)
(upbeat rock music)
- Batman.
- Batman, 100%.
- Batman, for sure.
Sorry, Brandon.
- [Franz] Yeah, sorry, bro.
- That's true.
I guess, after a while, I'd be like,
"God, I should've gone with Superman."
- Think of all the
gadgets that you'll have,
just laying around.
(upbeat rock music)
- Heat Wave, it's warmer.
- Heat Wave.
Yeah, it's warmer; I love warm.
- I still like the cold, and no.
- No.
- I think my family would
appreciate Heat Wave.
- I don't know.
I love them both.
- Diplomatic.
- I'd say Heat Wave.
I think he's so charming,
secretly under there.
- Yeah, he's a big cuddly bear.
- Captain Cold?
- Neither, that sounds
like a terrible idea.
I can't honor that question.
(upbeat rock music)
(groaning)
- Deathstroke 'cause Killer
Frost is way too cold.
- She's cold, man; she's so cold.
- She's bringing the
island temperature down.
I do not like that, Killer Frost.
- Killer Frost.
- I would go with Killer Frost as well
because I feel like I could maybe
still talk some sense into Caitlin.
- Killer Frost.
I could convince her out of
her state, like, whenever.
- Killer Frost.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Danielle Panabaker.
- Come on!
I'm with you.
- She's like Mama Bear.
She would take care of me.
- Ooh, ooh, that's thinking ahead.
I like that.
(upbeat rock music)
- Invisibility.
Hah! Yes!
- Invisibility 'cause I'm so nosy.
- Invisibility would be fun
to see what everybody's saying about you.
Are they really telling
the truth about you,
how they feel about you?
- Actually, that's so dangerous.
Super strength.
(upbeat rock music)
- Joker.
- Heath Ledger.
- Yes, Heath Ledger's Joker
or Jim Carrey Riddler, you pick.
(playful screaming)
- Neither, that sounds like a lot of work.
- Yeah, I'd rather
HBO Now with
The Penguin.
- Yeah.
(upbeat rock music)